laughs
got my life back we got our life we've
got our life back after four and a half
years five and a half because of Mark
yep
and being able to put the truth out of
what happened don't anybody ever forget
this was a massacre on February 14th
the only person to blame was that
monster it wasn't any law enforcement
nobody on that scene from BSO Coral
Springs everybody did the best they
could
we did the best we could with the
information we had his inaction
contributed
to the pain of our entire community
and we don't understand how this jury
looked at the evidence that was
presented and found him not guilty
because it's not just a victory for
Scott it's a victory for every law
enforcement officer in this country who
does the best they can every single day
how dare prosecutors try to second guess
the actions of honorable decent police
officers
hahaha
yeah